MALE SPEAKER: Let's roll.
All right, A-camera
speeds, D-speeds.
FEMALE SPEAKER: #Love4Dev,
scene seven, take one, ABC,
come to mark.
MALE SPEAKER: So
the thing I love
most about being a developer
is that I get to actually solve
real world problems.
And I can do it without
kind of any special tool.
So I can just open
up a text editor,
put my code in, and then
start to actually see
the problem kind of being
solved in front of me as I go.
MALE SPEAKER: What I enjoy
the most is the bleeding edge,
the speed at which we
deliver new technologies.
MALE SPEAKER: Our community
is based on sharing,
that we do open source.
And by a kind of passing
our work back and forth,
we all get better.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
MALE SPEAKER:
Having every client
be connected to
the web at any time
is both a blessing and a curse.
FEMALE SPEAKER: The biggest
challenge developers face
is there is so much
information, there
are so many different tools,
technologies, and resources
for them to choose from.
And they're not always
the easiest to find.
MALE SPEAKER: Things
used to be a lot simpler.
We used to write code,
and we used to compile it.
And then we would be done.
Now we've got the
web to worry about.
We've got mobile to worry about.
And then on each
of these platforms,
there's separate tools.
MALE SPEAKER: Some
days you're just
like, I just want
to build, and I
don't want to kind of
bridge all these gaps.
MALE SPEAKER: Even if you stay
on top with all the releases
and all the API changes,
trying to figure out,
how would a developer
use this to provide value
to users out there,
that is also stressful.
MALE SPEAKER: What I really
hope we see over the next
maybe five years is
that people get access
to good connectivity,
cheaper data.
Through that, they get
access to the whole web.
FEMALE SPEAKER: There are
millions more people coming
on line throughout the world.
And for developers, it presents
a huge opportunity, not just
to expand, but to
think about how
to build custom experiences
that match the unique needs
of those new markets.
MALE SPEAKER: If
we're going to have
the same pace of innovation,
there are no signs
that it's going to slow down.
It's going to be a really,
really exciting future
out there.
MALE SPEAKER: There's
so much opportunity,
and you see so many unexpected
things every single day.
MALE SPEAKER: We connect
to everyone on the planet.
And that, to me,
is just amazing.